one of our next presenters starred in a
movie in which he played a man who had
the heart of a baboon which in my
experience is not all that unusual he's
here tonight with an actress who's from
Australia so when she left home it was
already tomorrow which means she knows
who won here are Christian Slater and
Nicole Kidman
today's media seems to dwell on our
movies grosses as if they were results
from horse races and in reducing romance
to finance they seldom mentioned that
seminal branch of filmmaking the
documentary the vitality of those films
has continued from the earliest
documentaries of horses in action to the
wonders of wraparound adventures in
space
we're beholden to the industrious
keepers of the flame of documentary
films they come in two lengths features
and short subjects for best achievement
in documentaries short subjects the
nominees are blood ties the life and
work of Sally Mann Stephen canter and
Peter Spiro chicks in white satin'
Elaine Holloman and Jason Snider
defending our lives Margaret Lazarus and
Renner bundle eesh for the best
achievement in documentary short
subjects the Oscar goes to defending our
lives
Margaret Lazarus and
thank you this award honors the women
and children who have suffered and those
who have lost their lives because of
domestic violence thanks so much to our
co-producer Stacy Cabot and to our
colleagues who worked so hard on
defending our lives and special thanks
to the brave women whose names voices
and faces made this film come to life
thank you so much domestic violence is
the leading cause of injury to women in
the United States please we need all
your help to stop this
congratulations winners we applaud all
those behind all the nominees and all of
those who made this year's documentary
features the nominees are the broadcast
tapes of dr. Peter David for pony and I
Pickens burg children of fate Susan Todd
and Andrew Young
but better off for worse David Collier
and Betsey Thompson
I am a promise the children of Stanton
elementary school Susan Raymond and Alan
Raymond the war room da Pennebaker and
Chris Hedges and the Oscar for best
achievement and documentary features
goes to I am a promise the children of
Stan elementary school Susan Raymond and
Alabama
oh boy
I want to thank mikaël fuchs in home box
office for the support of this
documentary many thanks to our friend
and executive producer Sheila Nevins for
her encouragement
I'd like to thank the school's principal
Deana Bernie for her belief that all
inner-city children can live up to their
promise want to thank the Academy for
this recognition and hope that this
award will help focus America's
attention on the 12 million children
living in poverty in this country and
finally I'd like to accept this award in
loving memory of my mother and applause
of arraignment who gave me so much love
and support over the years thank you
coming up Goldie Hawn Kirk Douglas and
an international dance performance